if there was ever a video game perfectly
suited for eSports it's rocket League
developer psionics already teased their
plans for the soccer with cars game but
now it's officially announced the first
ever rocket League Championship Series
and it's all going to be streamed on
Twitch psionics vice president Jeremy
Dunham said from the moment we hit the
pitch last July we knew that rocket
League was a legitimate eSport twitch
and its streamers have been an
instrumental part of our success since
we launched last July and that made them
a perfect match for us we couldn't be
more thrilled to be working with the
team that we respect as highly as we do
twitch and we can't wait to show the
world what we can do in eSports together
the first season kicks off this month
with three on three matches going for
three months until they're well down to
a championship and there's a hefty
seventy-five thousand dollars in prize
money on the line matches are only
played for the ps4 and PC versions of
the game for now so xbox one owners will
have to keep playing for fun if psionics
announces more or if the xbox one gets
out into the tournament you'll hear
about it from gamespot